This machine
suck up your clothes to make new ones
and then how is it possible?
Develop this machine in Hong Kong,
it's the garment too garment.
For its operation,
it is quite simple,
first of all the clothing to be repaired and disinfected,
then
it is transformed to obtain 1 canvas
and this canvas is then twisted.
Then comes the spinning stage,
it allows to obtain 1 very strong thread.
1 time this wire obtained,
it can be to make
new clothes.
But that's not all since the machine
Choose 1 scanner
3 D which allows to manufacture on site
tailor-made clothing.
The objective of this machine
is to show that we can reuse clothes
damaged to make new and
to fight against the 100
billions of clothes that are sold each year.
to follow other world-changing projects,
It happens here.